Article 13 has passed, everyone.
What we feared all along, has become a reality.
The internet as we know it, is gone.
It's obviously really upsetting.
I think a lot of people don't know what's gonna happen.
But people have been saying things like:
"Now memes will be banned."
"Now all this content from Europe will be banned."
YouTube have been saying that they might remove content completely from EU.
It's obviously a big change coming.
And that's why I have a great deal for you guys.
Honestly, we didn't know that article 13 was gonna pass but I've teamed up with Nord VPN which is an amazing VPN.
I use it myself.
Article 13: gets passed
My VPN: This is America.
That's right, there's a simple solution to all this Article 13 mumbo jumbo.
VPNs, baby.
In case you don't know, a VPN lets you browse the internet as if you were anywhere - almost anywhere in the World.
Jokes on you, European legislation. I don't understand.
So, Nord VPN. It's a great service. You can even use it  on your phone. It's super simple to use.
And right now, we have a great deal, that you don't get just 50% off.
You don't get 100% off.
You get 75% off if you entered the code, ¨PewDiePie¨
nordvpn.com/pewdiepie
It's only $2.99 (£2.29) a month.
That's a great price. I mean, honestly that is pretty cheap.
And you get one month for free because you entered the code, "PewDiePie"
So, good for you.
What a way to troll the European Union.
*chuckles*
There's obviously other reasons to use a VPN especially for security reasons.
What? You don't care about internet security?
Pfft! What a loser.
Pathetic, okay.
You need to care about these things, you know?
All your data could easily be stolen.
*snaps fingers*
Just like that.
If you have a VPN, it's protected. It's protection.
Thank You, Nord VPN for sponsoring this video and now let's get on with it.
*mimicking gunfire sounds*
Skrrrrra.
*pop noise followed by an exhaled "aah" sigh*
*mimicking car swerving noises*
Skrattar du. (Swedish: You laugh.)
Welcome, all new subscribers.
Ever since this T-Series vs PewDiePie thing.
My channel has just been abundantly inflated with subscribers.
But really, this is it.
*breathy chuckling*
It's just me in a bedroom looking at stuff on the internet.
I want that to be clear here. I don't want there to be any higher expectations. This is all that we're doing.
We're gonna go, "Haha!" over a bunch of clips today.
Now, since we have so many new subscribers, I decided to create this new show called, "You Laugh, You Lose"
We're testing this out. Please be patient. We'll see how it goes.
But basically, the rule is simple: you laugh, you lose.
Let's freaking go.
Hey look, it's me. It starts with me.
T-Series.
35 years
How long does trash live? A thousand years!
We don't need to cry anymore, we are winning.
That's right, everyone.
I don't know if we still are.
It's ironic how we made the "Congratulation" song to wrap up the meme - to stop the meme.
Oh God. *laughs and loses*
Oh, they're playing "Congratulations" now.
*sniffles* Great.
We finally did it.
We persuaded nine-year-olds from saying, "T-Gay" to "Congratulations" instead, amazing.
Well done. Comeback of the goddamn century. We'll go for another thousand years - another millennium, easy!
*Billy chuckling*
*laughs*
*PewDiePie doing a Jojo stand cry*
Oh.
Mandy: ("Your next line is..." in Japanese)
PewDiePie: Yes!
Mandy: "Buenos días, Mandy."
("Good morning, Mandy." in Spanish)
Billy: Buenos días, Mandy.
PewDiePie: What?
Billy: ("What!?" in Japanese)
No. Nooo. Noo. No- *laughs*
*Billy screaming in pain*
*explosion noise*
I- *sighs*
Jesus Christ.
I still haven't watched Jojo but I feel like with all the memes it will just never live up to the expectation.
"low quality yet high tier"
Oh, it's another one of these, huh?
Who will it-
Oh! Dr. Phil? Dr. Phil, kawaii desu ne. Sugoi. Ii desu yo. ("He is cute. Amazing! It is good!" in Japanese)
Dr. Phil-san. He's so beautiful. Absolute beautiful man. I miss him.
You know, I miss seeing him. I miss making videos of him. I wake up sometimes at night, wet, thinking about Dr. Phil
Man: Wow.
Man: Well, guess I'm gonna sow it myself.
Man: The heck?
Man: Mama! What's going on h-
*laughs*
That's funny.
Do people buy those cookies and just to put their shit in?
Then why are they so convenient to use for sewing stuff? Pathetic!
What is happening here? What is this?
Person recording: Oh no.
Oh. It's beautiful.
*cello continues to play*
See? All these life skills that parents try and emit upon their children -
that is never gonna give them anything in life beyond just random memes. I really appreciate that.
*laughs*
You know this kid had to go to like thousands of dollars of lessons -
just lead up to this moment.
I mean, I'm sure it's not that hard to play but still.
*cello plays*
No kid wakes up one day like I want to play that big weird guitar looking instrument.
Cello? Is that what it's called? No, it isn't. Shut up. I know what it's called.
"never touch jimmy fallon's hand"
Jimmy Fallon: You at one point-
PewDiePie: Okay.
Jimmy Fallon: played the piano laying upside down.
Jimmy Fallon: You were laying on the ground playing with your hands crossed.
Rami Malek: Yeah.
Rami Malek: Spoiler alert.
PewDiePie: What's gonna happen here?
Jimmy Fallon: Oh, sorry. Yeah, yeah.
*audience laughter*
Rami Malek: Please. Stop.
Jimmy Fallon: Please, there's other ones.
Rami Malek: No, no, no.
PewDiePie: Oh.
Rami Malek: That was something Freddie did-
*laughs*
What happened?
Jimmy Fallon: At one point played the piano laying upside down you were laying on the ground playing with your hands crossed.
Rami Malek: Yeah.
Rami Malek: Spoiler alert.
Jimmy Fallon: Oh, sorry. Yeah, yeah.
*audience laughter*
Rami Malek: Please. Stop.
Jimmy Fallon: Please, there's other ones.
Rami Malek: No, no, no.
Rami Malek: That was something Freddie did-
Jimmy always laughs. What happened, Jimmy?
Why was that not funny?
"Looks like he just got his whole life ruined"
"Another three months of heavy drinking and memory wipe therapy gone.
So he has a second emotion besides laughter.
Who would have thought? See that's the most surprising, I just assumed that he just laughs.
I've never seen another emotion from this man.
Oh my God. 'Ey, it's this one.
Oh, that's creepy.
Doctor Phil, no!
Spider-Man: What the f***?
Oh, it's based on "Us". Okay, okay. I got it. Okay. That's funny. I still haven't seen that movie.
Ah, that actually makes a lot of sense now. Now it's a joke.
Woman: Logan, tell me you did not just hit him.
Woman: Lucas, did Logan hit you?
Lucas: Yes! He hit-
Woman: Really?
Logan: He ate my f***ing waffle!
Oh, Jesus!
Logan, what a savage.
Is this Logan and Jake Paul?
Logan: He ate my f***ing waffle!
"Don't take a mans waffle"
Wait, Logan took his waffle?
Oh, well that changes it.
Woman: Lucas, did Logan hit you?
Lucas: Yes! He hit-
Woman: Really?
Logan: He ate my f***ing waffle!
He ate his waffle.
That's totally justified then.
Don't eat Logan's waffle. Everyone knows this.
Never touch Logan's waffle.
I really expected it to be a "I did not hit her. I did not."
No? Just me? Okay, moving on.
Oh yes.
Oh well.
*laughs*
It's these jokes that you know they're coming.
You know exactly what the joke is but it still makes you laugh because goddamn if a good old skrattar (laugh) isn't worth it.
Oh my God.
Oh, wow.
Ew. Whoa!
Ew!
Oh my God.
Is he drugged?
What is happening?
"Ur cat is a thot"
I like this. I just looked at the comment.
"PewDiePie is losing dumb f*cks. Start subscribing."
Thank you, fabulous_bacon for doing your part.
It's everywhere I look now.
Oh, damn.
Oh, Jesus!
Oh my God!
Oh!
How is this even po- Okay, okay, they broke.
Is he going to go perfect.now?
No, almost. Oh!
When is this taken?
The comeback.
Oh my God!
Oh my god, that's insane! How is that real?
Goddamn, just the beginning is amazing.
Pro players everyone.
Goddamn, that was amazing. I mean it wasn't funny but it still made me laugh. I guess that means I lose a life.
Oh, no. What am I possibly gonna do?
"Awkward Disney Channel wand ID's (with graphics)"
PewDiePie: Wait, what is this?
Hilary Duff: I'm Hilary Duff from Lizzie McGuire.
Hillary Duff: And you're watching Disney Channel.
They're laughing too. What is this? Is this real?
Director: Let's do one more.
Hilary Duff: Hey, I'm Hilary Duff from Lizzie McGuire and you're watching Disney Channel!
PewDiePie: One more for safety.
*laughs*
Director: You need to move your body a little bit more.
This is outtakes then someone decided to draw over the outtakes.
Raven-Symoné: Hi, I'm Raven from That's so Raven and you're watching Disney Channel!
PewDiePie: Oh God.
Let's see the mouse!
Wow! Incre-
Whoa!
Director: That's great.
PewDiePie: "That's great!"
Raven-Symoné: Hi, I'm Raven from That's so Raven and you're watching Disney Channel!
Oh, whoa!
Oh, whoa! Disney Chan- Oh!
Is this real? Please tell me this is real.
Tia Mowry: I get to draw!
Oh, wow!
Wow!
*goofy laugh*
Anneliese van der Pol: Hi, I'm Anneliese from That's So Raven, and you're watching Disney Channel!
PewDiePie: Oh God!
*laughs*
She drew a duck!
Anneliese van der Pol: I'm really excited! Okay.
All right, let's see if I can do it.
Dora's Father: It's a part of you but exploring is not a game.
Is this Dora the Explorer?
Dora's Father: And you don't look before you leap.
Dora: NOOOO!!!
It's like a fan-made one maybe?
Is this real?
Dora: I'm okay, Boots!
*laughs*
No.
So goddamn bad!
Well at least I didn't laugh.
Goddamn Sans meme in 2019.
Jesus Christ.
When will you kids learn?
Some triggered Nintendo Switch user going around saying that you take
a Xbox controller and a PlayStation controller
and hook them into the memory card slots of an old Nintendo Wii
PewDiePie: What happens then?
and then you take an external DVD Drive
PewDiePie: Okay.
and hook that into the-
USB in the back
along with a floppy disk drive
PewDiePie: A floppy disk drive?
and then you take this adapter right here.
PewDiePie: Uh-huh.
and then you attach it to the extra USB cord on the back of it.
Then you can hook this flash card reader-
PewDiePie: A flash card reader. Yes.
Connect an additional USB to the second port.
Then plug that into a Bluetooth headset and attach a wall adapter to this one right here.
Then plug it into a pumpkin nutmeg pie candle
PewDiePie: And then you can play Tuber Simulator.
Insert a spare GameCube memory card into-
PewDiePie: No? Okay.
this chip reader.
Then punch in
PewDiePie: That did not do anything!
"up, down, left, right, left, right, B, A, B, A" and allowed to type, "car Wii remote"
Now let's see if it worked.
PewDiePie: Oh my God!
I knew it.
Mum, we're buying an Xbox controller and a Wii!
My mum is not even here.
I don't know why I said that.
Unbelievable.
Oh god. Yes. Have I seen this?
"Resident Evil 2 but 1000% facial animations"
Okay, 200%
What the hell is that?
Ew.
Oh, it's a burger.
That's not too bad.
Wait, I'm cutting to the good stuff.
300%
That's how I eat.
All right, all right, all right. 1000%, let's go.
That's a tasty burger, right there.
Uh, it's not too bad- Oh!
The burger just that good...
that your whole face melts.
Hey, look, it's another PewDiePie. The only stuff that makes me laugh.
Boy: Mum, are you subscribed to PewDiePie?
Mother: No.
Boy: I'm going to live with dad.
Good, as you should. Get your mum and make her to subscribe, right fricking now. I'm waiting.
Hi, mum! Subscribe, please.
Thanks!
Did that work?
Incredible.
Almost all 9 year olds have a mum, right?
If we can get all the 9 year olds mums to subscribe.
Then we have doubles subscribers.
Alright, that was it for this week's "You Laugh, You Lose"
Smash like if you laughed and smash like if you lose and I see you broskis tomorrow.
You remember? Check out merch, check out merch, remember. And brofist at 100 million.
Very nice.
Look at this merch. Support the channel.
See you guys tomorrow. Bye!
What!? Tuber Simulator's becoming relevant!
No! No, don't leave!
No, please!
Sponsor Eagle, please do something!
Yes!
Yeah!
This game is still relevant, goddammit.